like health Northern Ireland has
confirmed ten more people have lost
their lives they're taking the total of
people who've lost their lives to covert
19 in hospital 292 in Northern Ireland
and we had an update as well from Nicola
Sturgeon about an hour ago as saying
that 48 people had lost their lives
taking the latest total in Scotland up
to near 500 as well and I'm just being
told I'm just seeing it coming through
on the wires this is the time of day
that we get the England data coming
through to us as well and yes here it is
confirmation from the NHS that a further
eight hundred and sixty-six people have
tested who have tested positive for
coronavirus have now died those would be
people who have been in hospital that
takes the total number of reported
deaths in hospitals in England to eight
thousand one hundred and fourteen a
little bit more data on that those
patients were aged between 27 and a
hundred and fifty six of those eight
hundred and sixty-six patients had no
known underlying health condition well
there we can speak now to Skye's Helen
Anne Smith who joins me from the
newsroom it's a grim landmark isn't it
Helen Anne when the total number of
people hospitalized people goes through
8,000 who have lost their lives
absolutely it really is and to drill
down little into that England figure
that you just read out there 866 more
reported deaths since yesterday it's
just we're saying that's the biggest
daily jump we've seen for a few days
certainly the last four days or so the
numbers were sort of leveling off a
little yesterday they were actually
slightly down on what they had been the
day before just worth thing we have to
be very careful about odd jumps here and
there the numbers are there's often
reasons that they might be anomalous but
I'm pretty sure on my quick maths that
866 is the highest daily jump we've seen
for England to run you through the other
nation worth just saying we get the four
nations of the UK report their figures
at slightly different times so Scotland
we had first today a total of four
hundred and ninety five people have
sadly died there that's up forty eight
and in Northern Ireland a total of 92
which is up by ten on yesterday we will
await the the UK total I'm just hearing
that the Wales total is also just coming
back but bear with me 29 further deaths
yesterday which brings the total to
three one five so 29 further deaths in
Wales as well we will await a UK total
as well which we tend to get from the
Department for Health and Social Care
it's just worth saying that the Four
Nations report on slightly different
timescales so those four numbers won't
necessarily add up to the the big UK
total if you like but is that is the
best number were able to use to compare
how these deaths are increasing and as
we keep discussing we need to look at
the speed at which these numbers of
deaths are rising to try and understand
a little bit about the way that the
virus is spreading and crucially in the
last week or so the percentage increase
of the increase of death day on day has
been going down so yesterday a 12%
increase that was up from down beg your
pardon from 15% the day before and
certainly at this time last week we were
looking at 23 percent increases two
weeks ago we were looking at 31%
increases so that is going down but just
worth always stressing at there's people
behind these numbers they are still
horrendously big numbers you know we're
talking of thousands of people having
lost their lives to this terrible virus
it's still very sad indeed